in the last few minutes we've also been
hearing from the Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau his wife has tested
positive for coronavirus he is now in
isolation let's have a listen to him
[Applause]
being we are thinking about all the
families across the country who've
received the same diagnosis but we're in
good hands we have full confidence in
Canada's health officials and
professionals
this means that upon my doctor's
recommendation I will remain in
self-isolation for 14 days I want to be
clear I have no symptoms and I'm feeling
good and technology allows me to work
from home of course it's an
inconvenience and somewhat frustrating
we are all social beings after all but
we have to do this because we have to
protect our neighbors and our friends
especially our more vulnerable seniors
and people with pre-existing conditions
we are following medical advice as
should all Canadians and on that note I
want to thank all of Canada's health
professionals and the public health
agency who are doing an incredible job
supporting and looking after all of us
yeah yahooza
make emoni paws so he have a CD or test
polakov adidas nerf in a test
been hearing they're from the Canadian
mr. Justin Trudeau who has said he is
self isolating because his wife has
tested positive for corona virus but he
has no symptoms of corona virus and is
feeling good but he said he was leading
by example at myself isolating we have
to do this to protect others he said
technology allows me to work from home
and I will continue to follow medical
advice